hey youtubers what's up so this gonna be
my Game of Thrones video about Qyburn so
he's loosely tied to this little I did
my Citadel video last week so this is
just a continuation of that I've also
got news about the IMAX trailers the
screening and the season 5 premiere date
so I'll talk about all that stuff after
I get done through Qyburn Kai Byrnes
nickname is the bloody maester he
definitely earned that - he trained at
the Citadel but the Conclave of
archmaester stripped him of his chain
because he was performing experiments on
living people he was performing
vivisections that's when a surgeon opens
up a living person george RR martin
hasn't fully explained what those
experiments were but Kyra had said he
opened the bodies of the living to
better understand death that can mean a
lot of things I do have a couple
theories that I'll explain the Conclave
has a very narrow view of what it
considers proper areas of study
Qyburn is an extreme example of them
disciplining someone but they've also
ostracized people like archmaester
Marwan for studying magic and the occult
things that are not in vogue with the
Conclave so I'll talk about character
history as we've seen him on the show so
far and then I'll get into like theories
and spoilers so just look for this
spoiler tag in case you want to watch
out for that stuff after Qyburn got
stripped of his chain he joined the
brave companions as their healer he's
not a fighter and none of the major
houses of Westeros would hire him on the
TV show that groups represented by
Locke's posse here we met them for the
first time during season 3 when Locke
finds Jaime and Brienne fighting on the
bridge
so Locke in the book is actually Vargo
hOAT like they changed the character a
little bit they're one of the miners
sell sword groups from qohor Tywin
Lannister brought them to Westeros
during the war of the five kings in this
moment when we're seeing them they're
already working for Roose Bolton out of
Harrenhal the really cool thing is that
the first time we see Qyburn on screen
is right after the battle where Robb
Stark defeats Tywin Lannister's army
they capture Jaime Lannister Tulisa
stark finds Qyburn dying on the
battlefield rescues him but that was the
moment when the brave companions
switched sides so Qyburn in that battle
was actually working for Tywin Lannister
technically during that battle the
maester at Harrenhal was killed so
whenever Roose Bolton took over
Qyburn became the new maester so when
Locke brings Jaime and Brienne back to
Harrenhal - the hand
Qyburn is the one that sews him up that
cleans up the wound it's really funny
because the whole reason that Locke
chopped Jaime's hand off was because he
wanted to drive a wedge between Roose
Bolton in Tywin Lannister because
he knew that ruse was going to betray
Robb Stark and switch sides so he have
like the brave companion switching sides
and then their new Lord switching sides
back to the old side it gets really
confusing but that's one of the reasons
I love Game of Thrones it's just like
people go to work for other people that
are betraying people and then they all
switch sides so that's how Qyburn ends
up in King's Landing he goes back with
Jamie it's mostly a reward for saving
his life so that's how Qyburn ends up in
the good graces of Cersei Lannister he's
one of the best healers in Westeros like
that's his goal to be a good healer
that's why he studies human bodies so
much it's just the reason he seems so
shady is because he gives out that
Frankenstein vibe if you guys haven't
seen it there's this really awesome
Christopher Nolan movie called The
Prestige in it David Bowie plays Nikola
Tesla and he has this really awesome
phrase you're familiar with the phrase
man's reach exceeds his grasp is the lie
man's grasp exceeds is not first time I
tried to change the world I was hailed
as a visionary second time I was asked
for lightly to retire nothing is
impossible mr. Angela what you want to
simply expensively
Tesla was like a real-life genius
inventor but because Thomas Edison had
some competing technologies and the
intellectual community wasn't super hot
on him they pushed him into obscurity so
when you look at Kai burned here like in
this scene think of him as like a Nikola
Tesla figure the last time we saw him
was treating the mountain right after
that fight with Oberyn Martel the book
makes it seem more gruesome but the net
effect is still the same the mountain is
right on the edge of death and Qyburn
intervenes and that's the last we hear
about it like we're just left to wonder
like what are all these gadgets doing to
the mountain I read the books a long
time ago so I had an idea of what was
going on but when I first saw this scene
all I could think about is what is he
replacing those bodily fluids with so
the problem with the mountain is is that
the internal organs his internal organs
are essentially destroyed that's what
the venom did so Kai burns challenges to
replace those organs so here's where we
need to get into the books and theory
crafting so I'm going to put this
spoiler tag up in case you guys want to
skip past it so here we go I feel like
we're all thinking the same thing here
the mountain is Robert strong the
question is how do Qyburn do it I'm
inclined to think he's mostly using
science
don't think it's magic if it were Marlon
I would say it's the opposite but Qyburn
is all about human science and the best
theory I've seen is that he's
experimenting with stem cells to regrow
organs which actually sounds fairly
practical there's nothing black magic
about that so if you remember Circe had
given him Margery spire whoever she
thought was buying for Margery Snell to
use in experiments like he has her
chained up down in the black cells he
requested more women just saying that
she was really exhausted doesn't really
go into great detail why she's exhausted
it just sounds really sinister
eventually Cersei gives him more women
to continue his experiments but we
really don't hear more about it we're
still left to wonder it's possible the
Qyburn is using female reproductive
organs to cultivate stem cells and
regrow the mountain's internal organs
just replace the ones destroyed by
poison okay so spoiler part over now now
it's your turn let me know what are your
theories about what Qyburn is doing here
like what is going on in this process
here and how soon do you think they're
going to pay it off do you think we're
not going to find out till the end of
season 5 or do you think we'll find out
right away the show might simplify
what's going on I don't I don't expect
the producers to completely explain
everything in super detail for my money
though Qyburn is one like the new most
interesting people inside King's Landing
I say that in addition to the high
Sparrow like he and the high Sparrow -
like really awesome characters so keep
your eyeballs on them although then I
think they're going to focus mostly on
the high Sparrow just because he's one
of the main characters just as a
reminder to everyone I've got two copies
to hardback copies of feast for crows
and dance with dragons signed by George
R Martin very cool both very awesome
I'll be giving those away in my episode
1 video whenever that episode airs all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
but you know between now and then I'm
still doing my regular weekly giveaway
everybody wondering about that IMAX
trailer they just announced so they
haven't said which theaters are going to
be airing that stuff whenever they do
all add it in the description so just
check back on this video don't worry if
you can't make it to a theater they're
still totally going to post a trailer
online the screening start on January
23rd so I'll probably post my trailer
breakdown video that day or at least as
soon as they post something online I
don't want to post like cam footage or
try to pirate it or anything like that
the official premiere is April 12th
that's episode 1 they bumped it by week
probably because they're still
working on the new streaming service it
specifically designed for Game of
Thrones like they wanted you to be able
to get Game of Thrones with this new
streaming service it's based on the
Major League Baseball livestream app so
if you've used that it'll feel pretty
much the same
fingers crossed it does not crash as
hard as HBO go did last year HBO GO
failed so many times so the really cool
thing about the streaming app is that
you'll be able to watch episodes the
minute that they air you don't have to
wait an hour like HBO GO
so if you're like one of those people
who you know streams a lot of your TV I
just pay the fifteen dollars to get the
service it's only $15 you get a nice HD
stream and you can watch it as soon as
the East Coast feed premieres in related
news congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner
Brady Rose you and your choice of any of
George RR Martin's books just message me
on my channel for details
any paperback copy you want my next
bonus video is probably going to be for
the ancient houses and kings of Westeros
during Aegon's war a conquest like hair
in the black
feel free to make any request though I'm
going to be doing weekly bonus videos
for all the episodes just like I did
last year those will be a little bit
more relevant to like what's happening
in each of those episodes though so
while we all wait to find out which
theaters we can go see the trailer at
you can click here to learn more about
Aegon's war of conquest and you can
click here to learn all about the
archmaester citadel thank you so much
for watching everybody high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you